junko we'll be talking about
stimulations and by simulations for
probabilistic systems and their logical
content thank you
well of course I change the title but
it's about the same simulation has
disappeared but I'll mention it anyway
okay so thanks for coming so now I'm a
research fellow at Simon so it should be
I'm glad and grateful to be a research
fellow at Simon's and I want to talk
about ongoing walk about by simulation
for stochastic systems so let's start
was this the model so the first one
we're looking at as very simple Markov
chains so we have States and for any
state we are giving a distribution so
here D of Q means sub distribution I
actually almost never care from
distributions they can they don't have
to sum up to one so here from this state
we have the distribution one-third and
one-half so what we're interested in in
this is let's say we start from the
state on the left and if we do one step
then we will be in this distribution one
third here and we'll have here and then
I compute the sum of those two numbers
so I'm really interested in the
probability to still be in the Markov
chain after some steps all right here
there's one third here one half here and
you can think that there's somewhere
some bottom states some sink states that
is reached with 21 - those two guys okay
so at every point we're really
interested in the probability of
remaining in the Markov chain so if I do
just one more step then I will be here
is pretty 4/9 and here something and the
sum of those two is
so you can take your mark of change and
it can have labels so here I should say
that it's not exactly the same
terminology as for instance Prakash yes
so I believe Prakash would call this a
Markov process I just want to make a
difference because then I'll talk about
something so now I have a finite set of
labels or finite or they'll have to be
finite so here a and B if from this
stage we have a then there's one
distribution attached to it and if
there's a bid and it's a different
distribution so those labeled markov
chains i will see them as inducing this
function let's say it's the semantics of
this markov chain or something so when
you read a world a finite world then
you're looking at the probability you're
simulating it and you're looking at the
priority to still be there all right so
let's say for a then this would be
one-third plus one-third and then I
would continue okay so there's a labeled
markov chains and when i will want to
say something about them I'll talk about
the functions dangers
and now the third model is the one where
you actually add some control so which
is labeled Markov decision process and
here the control is not the actions so I
still have some actions but it is not
what you are controlling what you're
controlling is which distribution are
you taking so let's say we're here and
the letter A the peers then you have a
choice between this transition and this
transition so this distribution here
one-third one-third or this one which is
just 1/4 okay actually it doesn't really
matter for this talk but you allow
convex combination of those so if you
have the choice between this and this
you actually have the choice between all
convex combinations of those two
distributions it's important and I think
it makes sense for modernization but it
doesn't matter for so that means that
here where we have some control so we'll
talk about strategies which really tell
you in when you're simulating it this
this decision process when you have a
state and a letter which transition you
choose okay so it will be a function
like this so when you fix as a strategy
and MDP then it induces a Markov chain
I mean it just says you can do fine
since half of this distribution plus
half of this one yeah it's it's exactly
the same
yeah I could have written D of D of Q
but it would give you the impression
that it's random it's just a choice of
and yeah my phonetically it's D of D of
Q so does it make sense so yeah you
could do like half of this one plus half
of this one or one-third two-thirds or
even one-third one-third so now well
we're going to reason about stochastic
models there many questions you can ask
let's start with a simple one I give you
two labeled markov chains
so they induce these two functions and
I'm asking are those two functions equal
exactly equal so I'm not sure exactly
who should be credited for this result
being decidable I like to think of this
as a corollary of minimization for way
to determine da by shoots in the array
but there are different approaches for
this so let's go a bit more complicated
last year with Stefan Kieffer and Masha
show Normandy in Oxford we're thinking
about this problem that we called the
trace refinement so I give you on one
side an MDP and on the other side of
Markov chain of decision process so the
last one the one where you have choice
for the for the distributions yes sorry
I forgot to mention that we'll use
mostly acronyms and sometimes I recall
what it actually means
so I give you an MDP meaning that I have
to fix I have to give you a strategy and
I'm giving you a Markov chain so it
doesn't come with any strategy and I'm
asking can I find a strategy for the
first one that make them equivalent
meaning that if I fix this strategy then
those two markov chains now are
equivalents it generalizes this question
and well we proved that this problem is
decidable in Cohen P and surprisingly
you can ask almost the same question but
saying not for some strategy but for all
strategies so I give you an MDP m1 and a
Markov chain m2 and I'm asking is it
true that no matter what strategies I
take for the MVP it will be equivalent
to this Markov chain and this turns out
to be undecidable it's not the strategy
can be infinite memory so we don't know
if it's in n key we don't know if it's
in P when P is the best we have and I'll
talk about this of course this this is
so far what we know yeah
now I'm giving you an MVP and a Markov
chain yes and I'm asking you is it true
that no matter what the strategy you
choose is for the MVP can find a
strategy no the Markov chain is fixed so
all strategies will give you the same an
equivalent Markov chain which is
equivalent to the one you're given so it
seems to be very strong there are not so
many MDPs that are completely aware elec
oblivious to the strategy but this
problem is actually undecidable because
you can have very complicated strategies
that induce very complicated sort of
behavior and it's hard to detect that
all of them are equivalent
No yeah so I like in many cases the
answer is simply no and in some chronic
cases it happens to be very complicated
and this is what we sort of used to
prevent it a bit so why am I talking
about this because those two
decidability results we actually obtain
them by looking at the right notion of
by simulation so there's this notion
that to the best of my knowledge was
introduced by diamonds I hope they are
not checked people here troll and 13 ski
that defines by simulation not directly
as we are used to on States but on
distributions on States so just take
your Markov decision process this MDP on
which you are deciding for the next
distribution and look at the induced
infinite Markov chain we're sorry
transition system where you are the
states are the distributions of your
previous MVP and now you define the
usual by simulation for it so you say
that two distributions are equivalent if
for any letter A if you can do something
on one side then you can map it on the
other side and it remain equivalents
this is there and the other around if I
have dealt under two prime their
equivalent I can do something on Delta
prime then I can do this I can do
something equivalent on Delta such that
what I obtain Toronto primary credit so
this is just the standard definition of
by simulation but taking taking it over
distributions what we proved so first of
all let me start with a foie gras result
that if you take two Markov chains so
where you don't have strategies then
being by similar on distributions as I
explained just before it's just the same
as the equivalent saying that the two
functions for this Markov chains are
equivalent
and now if you're looking at MVPs if on
one side you have an MDP and on the
other side you have a Markov chain then
the similarity on distribution is really
the same as the question I was asking
before meaning does there exist a
strategy for the first one that makes it
equivalent to the second so this means
that to look at this problem you can
just look modern only add by similarity
on distributions and this is what we
prove to be in Cohen V so this is the
first part of my talk I we were walking
on this with Jeff and Kiefer and Master
sha imagine we found this notion
interesting the fact that we can relate
very verification type kind of question
to this by similarity and then walkin by
similarity which has some nice
properties and then I arrived here at
Simons and I started talking to Prakash
Pen engadin and bata clean and I
realized that I know just nothing about
roasting by simulation and there's a
whole world much bigger this is what I
was telling you about there's a whole
sets of planets that are all very
interesting and I'm going to tell you
about let's say the biggest one or at
least a very interesting one which is
the one you find if you ask Wikipedia or
Prakash it's the same answer what is
first if a simulation the notion has
been defined by a lesson and school in
91 and it's defined for Markov chains
not for Markov decision processes so you
don't have any choice there's just these
labels
the definition is the following it's a
an equivalence relation for states we
say that P and Q are two states that are
equivalent if for any action a you're
looking at some equivalence class of
your by simulation alright so a subset
of the States it has to be the case that
the priority from P reading a to go to C
is the same as from Q and so I'll get
back to this definition but let me first
remark that this is actually really
different for some deep fundamental
reasons from the previous one from what
I was telling you about
distributions let's look at this very
simple example we have P and Q and I'm
saying that they are equivalent in the
very first definition meaning that the
functions are the same because what is
the function here well in one step you
do 2/3 plus one-third so in one step
here is pretty one here and here pretty
one one half plus one half in two steps
you have 2/3 plus one half this is gone
sorry 2/3 times one half and here in two
step you have 1/2 times 2/3 so as
functions they really you cannot make
the difference but now according to the
by simulation that I just defined before
those two states are not the same and
the reason is that well those two are
really the same you cannot do anything
from them and those are also the same
because there's just no transition but
this one and this one are different
because from here you have 1/2 to go
there and from here you have 2/3 and
that directly implies that P and Q are
not by similar going to the Larsen and
score definition so they sort of capture
really some different properties that
you want to have about the system
it really took me some time to
understand this definition and in
particular words to the role of this
equivalence class and so on so the first
thing that we did here with vertically
NAND package was to get back to a very
usual definition of spoiler and
duplicator when I think about by
simulation I like to think I have some
sort of game where a spoiler will try it
will duplicate I will try to prove that
the two states are by similar and
spoiler will try to prove him otherwise
and they will basically spoiler will try
to make some move and duplicator will
have to match it and they will take it
from there so here's an equivalent game
and if you don't like this definition
and those are like completely
equivalents so you can think about the
game that's actually how I do it now
although this is really I mean there's
nothing really deep in the equivalents
so the game is the following you just
duplicate a games that p and Q are
equivalent spoiler we'll try to prove
that this is not true so he will pick an
action and a subset see any subset and
he will say look they cannot be
equivalent P and Q because from p.m.
from Q the priority to be in C to go to
C is different and well this is a fact
you're not discussing facts so this
cannot be discarded this is true however
duplicator can say well you cheated here
because the scene you gave me it's not
an equivalence class for this so there
are some states there that are
equivalent to some states outside of C
so duplicator picks the states inside
the state outside and it says well
here's how you treat it you told me that
those two are equivalent and they're not
and they are sorry thank you so so this
sort of I mean this shows dynamics on
how to prove or disprove that two states
are by similar for this definition and
you can think about one or the other
it's it's
so now I have just not so long to tell
you about 25 years of interesting
research on tracing by simulation so
I'll just mention a few highlights well
the first one I guess for all of these
to make sense and to back it up we can
compute this very stick by simulation in
P time it's actually P time complete and
I would say a second very strong point
is that this has a logical
characterization so you can define a
very simple logic such that if two sites
are similar then they satisfy exactly
the same formula conversely that means
that if two states are not by similar
then you can find a formula that
distinguishes those two and I see this
as a very strong point that this price
thing by simulation has really nice
properties and then there are extensions
I would say in a lot of different direct
directions you can instead of talking
about whether two states are by similar
you can talk about how by similar there
are so you can define distances to tell
you how by similar to States are you can
also have instead of equivalents you can
talk about some order on this so saying
that a state simulates another instead
of them being both ways similar that
comes with nice approximation techniques
and also you can extend this to crazy
systems that have infinite set of states
infinite sets of labels continuous time
dynamics and so on so this is a very
robust notion that has a lot of very
nice properties now the question that I
came up with is well all of this is very
nice we know a lot of nice properties
what are what is this definition good
for so what can we say about this do we
have also logical characterizations what
kind of things can we do with this what
so where does it fit in this big picture
so let me just remind you what other two
notions that exist in this small planet
there is this Trace refinement question
which is when I give you two MDP is the
following truth there exists a strategy
for the first one such that also edges
of the second one so this gives me
Markov chains those two markov chains
are equal and I to define a nice
relation a nice equivalence I will say
it also both ways so for any strategies
of the second one there exists a surgery
of the first so that's very cool so this
is what I call trace refinement I said
that m1 and m2 trace we find each other
if I can always not match each other
strategy and then there was this by
simulation on distribution and the first
results that we had last year was saying
well Trace refinement is undecidable by
simulation and distribution is decidable
and for the interesting case for at
least for one case then this gives you
some decidability for trace refinement
so what we did here at Simon's with
buttock hint sitting here was to find
logical characterizations so this is a
very simple logic that evaluates on
distribution of states so a distribution
satisfies a formula the formula are very
simple you have to you have conjunctions
you have a modality model operator I
would say as usual in this Hennessy and
an atomic formula that tells you what is
the weight of your distribution so when
you're looking at the distribution you
just make the sum of all the weights and
you're checking if it's bigger than some
number people and interested sorry the
interesting thing is that two
distributions are by similar if and only
if they satisfy the same formula of this
logic which really you should read the
other around if two still two
distributions are not by similar then
you can find formula that distinguishes
them that's really what you want to say
no it just is there there exists a
distribution so I if I read letter A
then there exists a distribution such
that from there we satisfy five so it's
not it's really the non-deterministic
parts and the parasitic version is we
hear when you are looking at the weight
of one distribution and now there's sort
of crazy fragments or crazy like some
syntactic fragments which restricts the
use of this conjunction so you don't
want to have adventures and then this
fragment wherever it precisely is
characterizes trace refinement so now
two distributions trace we find each
other if and only if they satisfy the
same formula of this form which again
you should read as two distributions do
not trace we find each other if and only
if I can find a formula of this form
that distinguish them and well this is a
sort of surprising thing you have a
logic the full logic whose
distinguishability
is decidable relation and you have a
fragment of it whose distinguishability
question is undecidable
so that's the picture of what I wanted
to tell you there was this notion of
pristiq by simulation on distributions
that turned out to be useful in some
questions that we were looking at it's a
motivated by verification of stochastic
systems
it was very enriching for me because it
made me learn all about a lot of
different things and now the question is
what is this good for the good first
thing that I'm happy with this well it
has at least one good property it has
logical characterization which of course
is incomparable to this one because the
logic that I define here it talks about
distributions distribution satisfy the
formula and here the state satisfies a
formula so it's not even the same
framework they cannot be compared and
this we've seen already that they really
don't tell you the same things about a
system thank you very much yes Larry
Rocco logic at the very end is it closed
under the one that's desirable and nice
is it closed in your vacation no I mean
so I mean what you would like to have
the let's say the strongest theorem is
that the weakest logic is enough to
distinguish so so for for my fear and I
took the weakest possible logic in which
I didn't need negation now what is your
question if you can do the same an ADD
negations then yes but so logic already
said close that your semantic negation
okay so yes the answer is we don't need
that so we don't add it
which is it clicked is it is it true
that the negation of ever not okay sorry
he's already closed up yeah well no
can you blow up the description of the
logic so this second logic I didn't
really understand how it differed from
the first is it the fact that the
diamond Phi's there cannot contain
signal the Sigma formulas so what you
should is like the difference is that
this is not closed under conjunctions
and how do you well exactly how do we
achieve this non curve I can put
arbitrarily nested things inside the
diamond day I can have died Monday time
and P Sigma P yeah but it has to be the
same formula that's the point so you can
say diamond a and diamond be diamond Fe
and I'm on a fee but not diamond a fee
and I'm on B side Prakash you cannot say
they don't have a conjunction of two
diamonds at the same length
typical graphic insanity yes yeah sure
what I mean is the distinguish should be
tribulation so the trace refinement is
undecidable and twice with refinement is
asking whether there exists so I give
you two two distributions when I'm
asking does there exist a formula that
satisfies one but not the other
and this is the in decidable problem of
this fragment yeah
so of this fragment you can decide this
and of this one you cannot it's not the
same as satisfiability sitting the way
written it yeah yeah so yes what I mean
by this proceeding so the two formalisms
are incomparable one doesn't you know if
the original your model and a 25 year
old they're incompatible I mean so this
is an so there are incomparable in the
sense that out of this definition you
can extend it easily to say that two
distributions are by similar for this
and then those two notions are
orthogonal meaning that you can find an
example where it's true for one and not
the other and vice versa vice versa but
they leave sort of in Indus in different
world from activities
so this is the right one I don't think
there's a right on I think the right one
is whatever you want to do with it and
this one it was for trace refinement the
other one has some a lot of different
applications the question is really what
can you do with it okay what's that pan
you're looking